the first time we were racing into space
it was about national pride the eagle
has wings
this time it's about money the
international space station is a near
zero-gravity laboratory dedicated to
scientific research the end of NASA's
shuttle program left the world with only
one way to get there
Russia we're proposed to pay over
seventy million dollars per seat to the
Russians just to go to the space station
it's just kind of embarrassing that the
United States has to thumb rides from
the Russians there is a better way a new
shuttle will soon take flight
but NASA won't be making it private
companies will and liftoff of the Falcon
9 rocket and dragon we're building this
in anticipation of a market emerging
NASA is hosting a competition for
private enterprise to build a spacecraft
to shuttle humans back and forth to
low-earth orbit and that contract will
be worth billions
I think commercial space today is much
like commercial aviation was back in the
late 20s and 30s it's being enabled by
the government but eventually it's going
to take off there's competition and
competition is good contenders in this
heated race Boeing SpaceX and Sierra
Nevada and the stakes are high
all multibillion-dollar aerospace
companies each determined to win the
NASA contract in order to become the
leader in the emerging space industry
SpaceX is the youngest contender born in
2002 from PayPal billionaire Elon Musk
his company set out with a lofty mission
to colonize Mars do you ever question if
you're crazy yes I think it's important
to question your sanity because at the
point which you stopped questioning your
sanity you're probably insane SpaceX's
dragon is a capsule design meant to hold
both crew and cargo and can stay in
orbit for up to two years
how much cheaper is it going to be to
send an astronaut to the International
Space Station using dragon dragon can
take up to seven people and if nASA uses
the full complement of crew and orders
for per year we can do it for twenty
million dollars per person it's a lot
cheaper than the 72 million dollars
person yeah
the SpaceX Dragon capsule is launched
into space by the company's own rocket
called Falcon 9 dragon is the first
commercial spacecraft in history to
deliver cargo to the International Space
Station and safely return to Earth a
mission previously achieved by only
three nations this is the first Dragon
spacecraft you can see the the heat
shield and the scorch marks this came in
like a flaming meteor how did it feel
and when that came back in one piece hey
[ __ ] right it's like wow I can't believe
it work we're kind of like a Silicon
Valley technology company that's doing
space what qualifies you to put human
beings in outer space every launch of
the Falcon 9 rocket which is the rocket
that would carry astronauts has
succeeded so it's got a hundred percent
success rate which is I mean the best
success rate of any rocket ever
boeing is known for airplanes but they
actually have a long history in space
since nasa's beginning boeing has been a
contractor on every manned space program
including building the parts for the
international space station boeing has
been in human space flight from day one
and so it's just part of our core we see
this as just the next huge opportunity
for Boeing and for NASA
how big do you expect the market to be
the development price itself is such a
huge barrier just a very different
business model than Boeing's used to our
huge development programs are typically
centered around commercial airplanes a
military aircraft where there is a lot
of orders and right now the foundation
of the business is two flights a year
Boeing's cst-100 is also a capsule
they're weld list design makes their
craft stronger and lighter than
traditional models
how many astronauts will fly in this
capsule right now we've configured it to
fly up to five but the cst-100 is
designed for up to seven we have a
significant experience obviously in
capsules from mercury and Gemini Apollo
the capsule was was an easy decision
what about comfort this isn't exactly
the most comfortable position I've ever
been in no absolutely but you could have
a very rough landing we needed to make
sure that this design would would
satisfy even the roughest potential
landing and then there's aerospace
insiders Sierra Nevada you've probably
never heard of that despite the fact
that they launched something into orbit
about every two to three weeks Sierra
Nevada has been around for over 50 years
one of the things people see when they
come here it's wonderful technology they
see a spaceship that's already flying in
a short period of time
you guys are up against Boeing and
SpaceX what makes you think that you can
take them on how many people knew Google
before they started we think dreamchaser
is the best transportation system for
what we do in space it's almost like
we're building the iPad and other people
are building the apps in the future from
that iPad
Sierra Nevadas Dream Chaser design is
the only one in the competition that is
not a capsule
it's a lifting body one model is the
only one that actually looks like the
shuttle what's interesting about this is
actually the volume inside is as much
usable volume as the Space Shuttle had
we could put seven people it would be a
comfortable fit and they could stay in
space for several days if they need to
with enough supplies really like a space
SUV yes so far there hasn't been a
capsule that's taken humans that's gone
up to space so one might have to build
20 or 30 or 40 capsules to do the same
thing that we can do with one space
vehicle when you look at the economics
of that that's a really important thing
all right let's jump in this simulator
okay look at the fast I see the runway
right there yeah doesn't fly like an
airplane but it lands like an airplane
the fact that the Dream Chaser requires
a landing strip that sets it apart from
the competition for us we can land
pretty much on any runway 8,000 feet or
longer in the world because we don't
enter like a capsule we pull a lot less
G's on entry we come in at a very low
one and a half GS so you can come in
land on a runway with a sensitive
payload the scientists can get to that
payload within 30 minutes because it's
right there on the runway every
spacecraft ever flown by NASA has been
built by a commercial company and
increasingly the government has
transferred the financial and physical
risk of the business to private
enterprise is there something at risk
with these big businesses entering into
the space industry the organization NASA
that had done this for many many years
is not doing it so we are sort of
sticking our necks out a little bit
we're taking a group of people
corporations that really hadn't been at
the development level and we're sort of
thrust in there and saying you go
produce make a safe system for me and
come back and let me know when you're
done but the benefit is that we get back
and forth much simpler
conquering a new frontier requires
having a destination for NASA that place
is the International Space Station it's
the most expensive single object ever
created projected to cost the u.s. eight
billion dollars in the end ISS costs 60
billion and that's not including
operating costs or the initial cost of
the shuttle program all in the price tag
is an estimated 150 billion dollars ISS
infrastructure is expected to last until
2028 before requiring costly maintenance
the government funding has only been
committed until 2024 if a manned
commercial space shuttle won't launch
before 2017 commercial companies will be
left with little time to make a profit
to justify the cost these private
companies are betting that there is
business beyond ISS there is a potential
for a huge business opportunity there is
going to be an incredibly robust and
interesting capability to get not just
American astronauts back and forth to
low-earth orbit but perhaps paying
commercial customers someday to a
destination it certainly doesn't exist
today fast forward 10 years I wish I
could look in my crystal ball and say
that this is going to take off and in a
matter of 15 or 20 years we're going to
have a couple space stations orbiting
the Earth
perhaps a hotel back and forth to which
we take you know wealthy but paying
passengers nonetheless it's about when
you build it will they come the original
space race was driven by nationalism the
new space race driven by the bottom line
of private enterprise in my case I have
an ideological Drive the thing that
really matters is to establish a base on
on Mars might be worse to become a
multi-planet species establishing
an insurance policy full for life itself
Elon Musk has sunk 100 million dollars
of his own fortune into SpaceX you see
then the Commercial Crew program as a
step in that direction is that why this
is important to SpaceX it's gonna be
helpful towards creating a base on Mars
for Boeing SpaceX or Sierra Nevada
winning this contract would secure their
company's survival whoever wins this
contest they set to be the next major
player in space exploration yeah I
really think so this is the time
well this design die if Boeing does not
win the NASA contract we'd have to go
back and see whether you could close the
business case by moving forward without
the help from NASA on the development
what will it mean for Sierra Nevada if
you lose this race if you don't win the
contract by time this decision is gets
made we would have had a lot of maturity
on the vehicle so there is a strong
likelihood that we will be able to take
what we've learned and move it to other
markets it would slow us down because we
would have less money to spend in that
direction but we continue launching
satellites as well as launching cargo to
the space station and bringing cargo
back from the space station every
spacecraft we've ever flown has been
built by a commercial company this is
just another way of procuring that
spacecraft I'm convinced that we will
have a reliable safe spacecraft when the
time comes to assign that country the
more we test ourselves and the more we
push exploration those smarter and the
better we benefits in our DNA to explore
that's what draws us to space we need to
continue to go beyond what we currently
know
you